[Music]
let's go to
uh let's see here's zach in chinatown
chicago what's up zach
oh not much how are you doing today dr
john we're just figuring it out my
brother how can i help man i'm good
well i gotta i got an issue well i guess
i don't know if it's an issue or not
that's hopefully you can help me out
with that um
so my mom she's been married three times
and she just can't seem to have a
relationship that sticks
and she just goes from boyfriend to
boyfriend she don't even
leave the one before she gets with the
other it's crazy and i have a
two-year-old and
she likes to spend time with my
two-year-old which is which is great but
the boyfriend is always around in some
way either he lives there or no she has
to do something nope
i'll solve that one for you answer's no
see and i always you know i'm married
but i always heard you know like with
divorces and stuff you
you should be uh careful of bringing
something new around i just didn't know
like i just didn't know if it was a huge
deal having someone eat you know because
they just visit for a couple hours or
whatever i didn't know
how to go about that
super super direct yeah man the number
of
young women i've met with over the years
i i can't even count
mom's boyfriend
step dad's
girlfriend
like the number of people who've had
negative interactions there i mean i
can't even count
so i don't know what the statistics on
that is
i don't want to overstate it
but two things are
sounding loud and clear to me number one
either you or your wife have some alarm
bells going off listen to your gut with
your comes to your kid okay
listen to your gut
number two it's as simple as
mom i love you so much
anytime you want to come over here and
be with kid that is great
i am overbearing when it comes to
um
people that i don't know interacting
with her child and so i don't want her
or him around any of your boyfriends
but honey they're just my no i'm sorry
mom i know i know it's weird and i know
it's a lot and it's probably me just
being a first-time parent that's fine um
but i don't want my baby around
um anybody that we don't know and that
we're not comfortable with
if you date somebody for a long time and
bring them around and i get to know them
and our wife gets to know him and we
both feel like that person's safe then
great but that's our decision to make
and it could cause drama it could cost
oh well then fine you're judging me
that's all
you can't control how mom's gonna
respond what you can do is protect that
baby little girl and that's not a risk
i'm willing to take
okay so
you're saying just uh you sound
disappointed again
you know six months a year down the road
whatever the case may be then it might
be okay they might not be a bad guy it's
just we have no idea yeah i don't care i
mean
like it's not my job to filter through
whether this i'm just gonna say i don't
want this person in my kid's life and
given your um like your description of
your mother's history there yeah i don't
want that in my life
you know what i mean what what is it
about the boyfriends that makes makes
you uneasy there's something that's
setting your alarms
off uh well it's just every boyfriend
she's had or husband there's always been
a problem her her first husband was was
my dad of course and they divorced
before i was
even two so i can't i can't tell you
what the problem was there but her
second husband
he was angry all the time always yelling
throwing things
and just just crazy situations and her
third husband same way so it's just her
judgment is always
off can i ask you a harder question i
never know what she's gonna bring home
so to speak so to say
she just never had good judgment so i
wouldn't expect the next one to have
good judgment even though i don't even
know who he is i just i just gotta
expect probably gonna be a problem so
can i ask you a hard question
does your baby need to be around your
mom right now
you know that's
that's a good question it's not a good
question that's a simple that's a
softball question
your mom is the common
denominator that's right that's right
and that's a really really hard
conversation
and i know that
yeah and i'm sorry that that's been
dropped in your lap there because the
picture of the perfect grandma that can
come by and
pick up the baby so we can me and my
wife can still go on dates all that is
so great man or just dropping the kid
off so i can go to target real quick and
home depot for a minute and clear my
head man and the christmases and all all
those
fantasy pictures are so good
it doesn't sound like your mom's a safe
space for that baby girl right now
and it might be that grandma can see
her granddaughter around you guys
when y'all are at i mean at your house
that sounds great
um
and it might be that you off to set a
broad boundary like we're not letting
her go to anybody's house right now
we're we're kind of circling the wagons
a little bit for a season
you're not gonna let her come see your
grandma no no you can come over here and
see her that's fine but we're gonna keep
her here and that's gonna impact you
guys it's gonna be hard
um because it's going to impact your
dating life and it's going to impact
your ability to run to the store and
stuff and your daughter's worth that
that fair yeah
yeah you're very right
i hate that for you man like just guide
a guy i hate that
and and it's just so tough because
my mom literally she bought a house
two houses down for me so she could be
around that's when she was a little more
stable and now
like i said all this stuff going on in
her life she's she's never even there
she just ran off to tennessee with her
new boyfriend this week
and that's hey it's weird it's your mom
dude that's so weird i know i mean and
if you go back and listen to this call
you're talking about your mom as though
you're 48 and it's your 22 year old
daughter
which tells me you have been i feel like
it is because you have been responsible
for the emotional regulation of your mom
your whole life
and that's not your job
she's an adult
and you've been carrying it and carrying
it and carrying it in part there's a
little voice in the back number one your
wife sees it all she sees it all doesn't
she all right
oh yeah yes so part of this maybe you
sit down with your wife saying hey
you're super right i'm sorry don't
please don't please don't bring this up
in a future fight i was wrong and we're
going to create some boundaries here and
they're your boundaries to create cause
it's your mom
um
but there's part of your body that
doesn't want your daughter having to
carry the same load that you've had to
carry
and so don't make her
and
dude i'm not for one second minimizing
this i know how hard this will be this
be the worst no worse the worst
but it's right
right
yeah yeah it is
i'll have some extra um i'll have some
extra chips and queso for you my brother
because i know this the whole thing will
be hard
maybe she'll sell the house in stan
tennessee and make things easier but
probably not maybe tennessee's a great
place to be
you can load up the truck and move to
beverly but man
i'm sorry
two houses down it's like the it's like
you're ray romano man oh jeez